[Musica]
grazie bellissimo bellissimo diceva
massimo russo una persona fortunata io
sono ancora più fortunato di lui perché
intanto ho ascoltato anche lui
sono qui da stamattina è quello che
proverò a fare in questi miei tredici
minuti sarà non solo proporvi una
visione che è appunto legata a quest
ultimo libro e quando mi hanno invitato
qui a parlare di sì che tecne non
sapevano che il libro è riuscita quindi
capite quanto sia stata una combinazione
fortunata ma dall'altro proverò anche a
raccontarvi contenuti di questo libro è
anche della mia attività attraverso un
metodo che è poi quello che io con il
mio gruppo di ricerca che appunto è il
feature concept lab mette in pratica
ormai da 30 anni questo è un istituto
che nato nell 89 e cioè noi osserviamo
abbiamo una rete di osservatori
ricercatori in tutto il mondo sono 50
ricercatori in 40 città del mondo che
osservano creano delle connessioni tra
quanto viene osservato e poi ci inviano
tutto questo materiale che noi a milano
dove abbiamo la nostra sede principale
proviamo a creare diciamo degli scenari
no quindi a dare delle interpretazioni
io farò questa cosa
partendo dagli interventi che abbiamo
ascoltato oggi quindi ringrazio anche
tutti i relatori che ho ascoltato perché
questo è secondo me il modo migliore di
assorbire metabolizzare una giornata
come questa quindi vi consiglio dopo
aver essere in qualche modo stati
bombardati per queste ore da ognuno di
noi che in 13 15 minuti vi ha proposto
una visione del mondo provare e tornando
a casa a mettere in ordine queste cose
ma lasciare anche che sia la vostra
intuizione
a cogliere le cose che vi hanno colpito
di più è a intrecciarle con la vostra
vita quotidiana per fare questo è molto
importante avere una sorta di scacchiera
su cui andiamo a muovere questi pezzi
questi spunti questi stimoli
oggi ad esempio tutti noi abbiamo
ricevuto questo è un po quello che io
farò ma partirò intanto dalla copertina
di questo libro perché molti dei
relatori hanno parlato in fondo di
questo il rapporto tra psiche e techne e
quindi tra la dimensione umana dei
sentimenti come li ha definiti oscar
farinetti e quella della tecnologia che
comunque non dimentichiamoci è comunque
frutto del nostro essere umani è una
partita a scacchi ancora assolutamente
aperta
questo secondo me è molto importante ci
dobbiamo evitare da un lato la tecnofili
a pensare che la tecnologia ci salverà
che il mondo procede in modo progressivo
no ce l'ha spiegato bene farinetti in
realtà il medioevo è la dimostrazione
che si può tornare assolutamente anche
indietro no rispetto ai valori che sono
stati fino a quel momento proposti ma
dall'altro
l'altro grande errore a cui noi italiani
siamo più soggetti e la tecnofobia cioè
quindi quello di demonizzare la
tecnologia di demonizzare quella parte
del cuore che vedete che è meccanica
pensando che quello ci sta rubando
l'anima ci sta in qualche modo
costringendo ad accettare un mondo che
noi non desideriamo
quello che invece io voglio proporvi è
che questa è una partita assolutamente
aperta dove i pezzi sono sulla
scacchiera la partita comunque come
sempre la facciamo noi ma dobbiamo
capire la strategia dobbiamo capire come
arroccare e quindi in alcuni casi
difenderci anche da un eccesso di
pervasione tecnologica ma anche come
attaccare come provare a dare scacco
matto come provare a usare invece queste
straordinarie tecnologie per portare a
termine il nostro diciamo obiettivo il
nostro sogno è stato definito in tanti
modi
oggi diciamo anche il nostro progetto di
vita ecco io credo che io insegno al
politecnico a giovani designer e insegno
è una classe che arriva da tutto il
mondo ragazzi perché per fortuna almeno
nel mondo del design
milano e l'italia ancora è un luogo che
è assolutamente considerato il migliore
del mondo quindi ragazzi che arrivano da
tutto il mondo e io insegno social
innovation cioè insegno una materia che
è innovazione non tecnologica ma come
l'innovazione tecnologica o come
l'innovazione diciamo nei sistemi di
relazione umana quindi le società
possano e debbano affrontare questa
grande sfida dell'innovazione ecco
allora da questo punto di vista passo al
sottotitolo del libro sottotitolo del
libro può sembrare una provocazione può
sembrare anche una sorta di appello
contro intelligenza artificiale ma non
lo è ma è l'indicazione del suggerimento
che vi do provate a immaginare a capire
tutto quello che ci appartiene che è
profondamente umano e che non potrà mai
essere proposto dall intelligenza
artificiale prima loretta falcone ci ha
dato un esempio straordinario no per
questa dimensione
lei l'ha chiamato il fuoco dentro di noi
è una cosa che l'intelligenza
artificiale non potrà mai né imitare né
ripetere in alcun modo
e allora qual è la prima indicazione che
io vi do per affrontare in modo
intelligente la grande sfida
dell'intelligenza artificiale non
dobbiamo solo specializzarci
intelligenza artificiale ma dobbiamo
rafforzare tutto ciò che l'intelligenza
artificiale non ci potrà mai dare cioè
dobbiamo diventare ancora più umani ecco
da qui il titolo futuro più umano non è
detto che il futuro sia o sarà più umano
in questo senso potrebbe anche essere
distopico qualcuno stamattina ce l'ha in
qualche modo fatto intravedere no questa
distopia dipenderà da noi
ecco allora questo vuol dire caricarsi
di una grande responsabilità che è
legata al tema sicuramente noi oggi
abbiamo più potenzialità di quanto dieci
anni fa ho 50 anni fa due secoli fa
avessero i nostri genitori o avi ma
dobbiamo capire che questo deve
corrispondere una maggiore
responsabilità perché altrimenti il
rischio è quello che vediamo in questo
diciamo questa è la scacchiera che io vi
propongo che anche
che la struttura del libro è la
struttura del progetto su cui noi stiamo
lavorando anche col festival della
crescita che appunto è stato prima
citato e c'è dobbiamo capire quali sono
le forze in campo no in questo momento
in questa fase
e allora qui senza voler essere
hegeliani vedete un po una sorta di
partenza che sono i problemi quindi una
sorta di tesi critica di quali sono i
problemi che noi oggi dobbiamo
affrontare poi c'è una sorta di antitesi
di passaggio di possibile antidoto mi
verrebbe da dire che sono le parole che
vedete al centro e poi una possibile
sintesi che poi vedrete riguarda in
particolare l'italia la cultura italiana
ma potrei dire anche il veneto visto che
siamo a treviso perché poi mi è capitato
di lavorare molte delle persone in sala
lo sanno abbiamo lavorato insieme sia
nel mondo dell'industria del mondo
dell'artigianato nelle scuole
abbiamo spesso delle qualità dei talenti
che non siamo in grado di valorizzare di
moltiplicare allora cominciamo questo
gioco partendo anche proprio da quello
che ci ha spiegato carlo tunis
stamattina e che mi ha molto colpito
sentito anche molti di voi sono rimasti
colpiti dal fatto che noi abbiamo un
cervello che si sta in qualche modo
rimpicciolendo me questa cosa
francamente non è che piaccia tanto poi
lui dice ma poi c'è intelligenza
distribuita ok però dobbiamo capire che
probabilmente stiamo delegando troppo
noi stiamo diventando diciamo ci siamo
infantile infantili zandonà o di mistici
zando come lui ha detto e questo vuol
dire poter cadere nell'errore del
capriccio da un lato nell'errore o nella
possibilità di essere passivi pensate il
paradosso quando si hanno tante libertà
il vero rischio è di non riuscire più a
scegliere quando e lì per scelta vanno
entrato in un supermercato con migliaia
di prodotti alla fine si può anche
uscire senza aver comprato nulla oppure
si compra la prima cosa che capita
quindi da questo punto di vista il caos
da questo punto di vista può
assolutamente essere un rischio anche se
viviamo nella società più libera di
sempre
e allora ecco vedete le tre parole che
sono antidoti e devo dire sono state
tutte e tre molto bene proposte
stamattina
nel primo pomeriggio il primo è la
curiosità non lo ha spiegato benissimo
farinetti qualcun altro l'ha ripreso
questa idea che dobbiamo attraversare la
diversità con l'idea lui diceva dobbiamo
imitare
io dico anche e qui cito invece picasso
che diceva imitare da uno è plagio in
italy da tanti e creatività
allora iniziamo da tanti nel senso
cerchiamo di prendere anche da questa
giornata le cose che ci hanno colpito di
più proviamo a metterle insieme a
connetterla e vedrete che riuscirete in
qualche modo da avere un pensiero vostro
un pensiero nuovo un pensiero davvero
creativo
ecco che però questo elemento di
curiosità e poi di passione che vuol
dire andare verticalmente sui vostri
talenti deve devono entrambi però
prevedere l'altra parola in cui noi
siamo un pochino meno forti e che è la
cura prendersi cura delle cose che
facciamo
la cura del dettaglio gli americani
dicono execution lavorando nelle aziende
dicono la creatività vale 5 poi e l'ex
cushion che vale 95 per cento
ted ne è la dimostrazione un format che
funziona così bene perché è stato
perfezionato anno dopo anno dal 95 ad
oggi
e guardate come possa funzionare no in
un luogo in una cultura completamente
diversa da quella americana
questa è una cosa dove noi dobbiamo
davvero fare un salto di qualità
dobbiamo capire spesso di avere le cose
più difficili perché noi abbiamo il
salento abbiamo l'intuizione abbiamo il
colpo d'occhio abbiamo l'empatia
abbiamo tutte quelle cose che
l'intelligenza artificiale non può
garantire
ma non lo capiamo c'è un problema di
consapevolezza perché quell ultima riga
che vedete il gusto
noi non siamo forti nel lusso lì sono
più forti francesi cioè il gusto per
pochi i no per pochi eletti
noi siamo molto forti nel gusto pensate
al cibo pensate a come ci vestiamo alle
case che arrediamo perché perché abbiamo
attraversato la bellezza per secoli e
quindi è difficile non avere gusto se
attraversi tutti i giorni piazze
meravigliose
chiese o hai comunque un'infarinatura
rinascimentale certo dovremmo
probabilmente studiarla di più e
comprenderla di più
ingegno leonardo da vinci i grandi
inventori e prima c'è stata data una
bella dimostrazione di ingegno nel senso
mettere insieme la danza con l'ologramma
no è sicuramente una capacità che noi
abbiamo perché noi non siamo così
schematici come invece tante altre
culture sono non siamo così strutturati
quindi o poi in più sono anche
napoletano l'ho capito dal mio modo di
gesticolare quindi chi non è abituato a
seguire le regole ha e avrà dei problemi
però anche un vantaggio che è il
pensiero laterale che quello che chi è
molto strutturato difficilmente riesce a
proporre
ecco allora quello che io vi dico e
quindi torno all'italia e al veneto e
che paradossalmente noi oggi possiamo
godere del vantaggio del ritardo cioè
non avendo fino in fondo assorbito una
cultura che quella classica manageriale
molto strutturata quella diciamo pure
della globalizzazione
possiamo oggi proporre quello che dice
la farinetti e cioè pensare locale ed
agire globale
il problema è che però dobbiamo
viaggiare dobbiamo imparare le lingue
dobbiamo attraversare la diversità
perché l'ingegno ci appartiene perché
un'idea può essere applicata questo su
questo noi siamo bravissimi siamo
inventori di macchine per la produzione
non inventiamo tutto perché abbiamo
questa capacità di passare dal tessile
alla meccanica di alta precisione
abbiamo una visione che a 360 gradi che
a volte è vero è un po dispersiva ma poi
quando funziona ci porta in qualche modo
in un luogo straordinario di qualità
ecco l'ultima parola
e allora per chiudere qual è
l'indicazione finale che io però vorrei
dargli perché in questa giornata c'è un
unico possibile problema che è quello di
pensare che poi il sogno si realizza
sempre quello di pensare non a caso
vengono chiamate persone come me come
altri che hanno realizzato il loro sogno
ma guardate che questa non è la norma
non è diciamo lo standard lo standard di
persone che ci provano che devono in
qualche modo rivederlo questo odio e
quindi dobbiamo fare come la bravissima
danzatrice a cui poi dedicherei
l'applauso che ha continuato ad alzare
anche se non c'erano le bolle non
c'erano i sogni lei ha continuato perché
è una grande professionista ha capito
che qualcosa non andava ma ha continuato
e quindi poi abbiamo potuto rivedere il
tutto ricomposto questo è quello che
alla fine nel 99 per cento che vi
ritroverete a fare cioè avere un sogno
doverlo rivedere non perdere mai il
coraggio non perdere ma la
determinazione ma capire che dall'errore
e dal rivedere qualcosa da lì nasce la
realtà quella che alla fine ci può
soddisfare e rendere felici grazie